space
time reality it's more
than a linear path it's a prism
of endless possibility well that
doesn't sound ominous at all
i was promised an army
you have a super soldier
Cool! You sure don't seem too freaked out about all
this kid what you doing out there all by yourself
anyway exploring the world sounds fun but why
stop at one world when we can show you all of them
i am the watcher
i am your guide through these vast new realities
follow me and dare to face the unknown
and ponder the question
what if?
give me the tour
shifting to marvel studios first animated
series coming to disney plus next summer what if
flips the script on the mcu taking famous
events from the films and reimagining them
in unexpected ways we've assembled a stellar voice
cast with many mcu stars reprising
their roles here's a look at what if
Welcome back everyone it's Charlie this is
going to be my new marvel what if trailer
video for the new series that's coming next year
i'll explain what's going on with the episodes
who's coming back and how they're breaking all
the different movies up because they're doing
one episode for each mcu movie that they've done
so far and probably in future seasons the future
marvel phase 4 movies as well if you're new to the
channel be sure to subscribe to get all the videos
we're doing a disney plus giveaway for memberships
all you have to do to enter is be a subscriber
and let me know which what if episode you're most
excited for which mcu movie really curious to see
how they adapt marvel zombies because obviously
that's going to be one of the avengers episodes
just based on the people's costumes but really
important stuff first there'll be 10 episodes
total it's releasing next summer they didn't say
exactly when but it'll be a couple weeks after the
loki episodes have released and loki starts in may
so it'll run till they release shang chi and the
legend of the ten rings at the beginning of july
so i'm assuming that the marvel what if episodes
will start just a little while after shang chi and
the legend of the ten rings hits theaters so like
the middle of july and i know we haven't seen a
trailer for shang chi yet but we'll get a trailer
for that pretty soon most of the mcu actors are
coming back to play their characters they showed
off a big one sheet back at comic con last year
that's also probably been updated because they
probably signed some more deals since then but
they've been working on this series for the past
year that's why all the episodes are getting
ready to go the animation looks great it almost
looks like spider-verse animation but if you don't
know who's playing the watcher it's jeffrey wright
they announced him at comic-con last year his
voice probably sounds familiar because it's so
identifiable and he's been showing up on so many
hbo series recently but as you can see from the
footage it seems like they're jumping around in
the mcu timeline with the way they do the episodes
so even though they're doing one episode for every
mcu film they're not going in a linear fashion
doing the phase one movies and the phase two phase
three season one will be a mixture of phase one
phase two and phase three movies but his dialogue
obviously highlights the infinity stones he says
space time reality it's more than a linear path
it's a prism of endless possibility talking about
the multiverse they kind of got into that during
avengers end game with the multiple timelines
the big twist of the loki series is that it's
loki going after a bunch of alternate versions
of himself with different timelines because the
time variance authority caught on to him when he
stole the space stone and started jumping around
messing with events in world history i've already
done a big video for the loki trailer so i'll
link it in the description and at the end of this
but if you couldn't tell the reason why it looks
like there are a bunch of different loki's in that
is because there are a bunch of different loki's
he's both the hero and the villain of that series
and when i say they're doing multiple alternate
versions of loki that also includes female
loki from the comics i think a lot of people
didn't read the comics they didn't understand
why there's a female version of loki out there
i believe they're also doing kid loki and other
older versions of loki as well so more versions
than just the different tom hiddleston versions
if it sounds like rick and morty in
the mcu that's because it kind of is
the showrunner of the loki series actually came
from rick and morty right before he started
doing the series but then you get the dialogue
saying i am the watcher i am your guy through
these vast new realities follow me and dare
to face the unknown and ponder the question
what if the dialogue is actually taken from
the beginning of all the marvel what if comic
books like at the beginning of most marvel comic
books there's some kind of intro or some sort of
opening crawl that tells you what's been happening
to kind of pick you up on the series if you're
jumping in mid-run the speech from the watcher
was at the beginning of all the what-if comics
but just going through the footage shot by shot it
seems like we start with nick fury finding captain
america shield in the ice i'm assuming that this
is during the events of the first avengers movie
then there's a scene of t'challa star-lord doing
all the same scenes from the first guardians of
the galaxy movie when he was on morax stealing the
power stone this seems like it's a guardians of
the galaxy episode and what they've swapped is
that it's t'challa instead of peter quill that
winds up being star-lord there will eventually
be a black panther episode the plot of that
will probably be very different and take place
in wakanda on planet earth then we have doctor
strange activating the time stone inside the eye
of agamotto during the first doctor strange movie
then there's nick fury inside what seems like
project pegasus from the first avengers movie
when he says well that doesn't sound ominous
that might be the scene when loki arrives
through the portal in the tesseract then we see
peggy carter getting the super soldier serum
during the events of the first captain america
movie instead of steve rogers becoming captain
britain the reason why they don't call her captain
america is because she's part of the british army
not the american army so when she's attacking this
convoy she's wearing the captain britain costume
but they've also painted captain america shield
to look like a british flag because she's captain
britain so i'm assuming that there is no captain
america in this timeline then yondu and the
ravagers arrive in wakanda to pick young t'challa
up and take them with them either he's ego the
living planet's son in this reality or they have
some way of explaining how peter quill isn't the
one to go with the ravagers in this scene chadwick
boseman was listed on the cast so i don't know if
he recorded his dialogue before he passed away or
if they got another actor to come in and dub his
dialogue for him i'm sure marvel will explain
when the actual episodes come out next summer
they confirm that michael rooker is back to play
yondu during the series he basically tells young
star-lord why don't you come with us and explore
the universe then this is doctor strange at the
beginning of the first doctor strange movie when
he first comes to the ancient one to learn magic
him going through the same cosmic tour of
the multiverse that she sent him on before
then we see captain britain writing the world war
ii version of iron man's armor built by howard
stark worn by this version of steve rogers so in
this reality steve rogers winds up becoming iron
man peggy carter winds up becoming a version of
captain america because it's world war ii though
and they haven't really gotten to this point of
miniaturization in modern day with the newer iron
man armors it's built to look like a tank it
almost looks more like the iron monger armor
i don't know what their explanation is going to be
for why steve rogers doesn't get the super soldier
serum they'll have some way of explaining that
twist then this scene of winter soldier fighting
zombie captain america seems like it's coming from
avengers infinity war because he's wearing his
costume from infinity war so it sounds like the
marvel zombies episode is the infinity war episode
of what if then a real big twist this seems like
an evil shadow twin of doctor strange manifesting
for some reason during the events of the first
doctor strange movie that's what this thing
behind him is you see it later in the trailer when
they're battling each other just an evil version
of him comes to life the director of the first
doctor strange movie scott derrickson said that
when they were trying to envision what dormammu
was going to look like during the first doctor
strange movie they said that they thought of him
as sort of an evil aspect of doctor strange like
he was meant to portray himself as if he was some
sort of evil mirror for doctor strange and even
though he's this giant extra-dimensional being
that's just the way he looked to doctor strange
so when you see doctor strange fighting this evil
version of himself that could have something to do
with that original idea from the first doctor
strange movie this is a scene of loki and the
asgardians addressing the united nations it's also
probably from the events of the first avengers
movie or the first thor movie because there's a
couple scenes in here from an episode that's based
on the first thor movie this part of the sanctum
doctor strange walks into just looks like a larger
version of the library than we saw during the
first movie the sanctum is this multi-dimensional
nexus point and it's also kind of like the tardis
from doctor who bigger on the inside i wouldn't
be surprised if it's as big as the avengers tower
if you were to actually see it as it really exists
this is just more scenes from that first guardians
of the galaxy movie inside nowhere when they're
taking the power stone to the collector the
episodes themselves are probably only going to be
about a half an hour long maybe a little bit less
than that so when they're doing the plots of all
these different movies in the episodes we'll see
how quickly they speed through stuff this scene of
hawkeye is from the events of the first thor movie
when he's in his perch watching thor trying to
steal his hammer back for the first time then we
get a confirmed iron man episode this is iron man
and the donut from the events of iron man 2. so it
sounds like their iron man episode during season 1
is the iron man 2 episode there were all kinds
of rumors about robert downey jr coming back to
reprise his character but he's also been doing
interviews saying that he's done everything he
could with it so i don't know if he's actually
going to be him in the episodes or they just got
someone that sounds like robert downey jr to be
iron man for these it's really hard to tell when
this scene of captain marvel is happening which
movie it's from if it's from one of the avengers
episodes like the marvel zombies episode or if
they're doing a captain marvel episode from her
movie because she's already got the costume on
and she didn't really get that till the very end
of her first movie or even really learn about how
her powers worked this is just another scene of
captain britain in the howland commandos doing the
same charge in scene from all the trailers for the
first captain america movie this is obviously thor
from the events of the first thor movie running in
to try and pick up the hammer for the first time
after learning that shield had found it this scene
also seems like doctor strange from the events of
his first movie with christine palmer their rachel
mcadams character who's also coming back for
doctor strange 2 they actually just announced that
it seems like he's been fighting his alternate
shadow twin and whatever's going on between them
with their full-blown wizard battle it's led to
the utter destruction of the world like look at
the crumbling new york city skyline behind them
one of the funnier things about those classic
marvel what if comics is that a lot of them had
really really dark endings then i love this scene
of t'challa star-lord talking to howard the duck
going on a tour of the collector's fortress all
right give me the tour but like i said obviously
this is just a fraction of the mcu movies they've
been 22-23 so far if you include spider-man
far from home obviously black widows coming up
they intend to do episodes for every single mcu
movie that also includes the spider-man movies
so spider-man homecoming spider-man far from
home spider-man 3 which kind of seems like a
spider-verse episode it'll be funny if they
actually did an animated episode with all
the spider-verse characters showing up in
that but because there's only 10 episodes
during season 1 that pretty much confirms that
they will be doing multiple seasons of what if
if you didn't see my other marvel trailer videos
for all these upcoming disney plus series what's
happening is is they're going to be dropping three
to four disney plus marvel series every single
year but not all the shows are going to get season
two some of them will just be limited miniseries
of course i'll be doing episode videos for all
this stuff i'm really excited to see what it
actually looks like what they actually do with
some of these characters given that it's what if
it's pretty much anything goes i've still got
a couple other big trailer videos from the past
week to do and we have the mandalorian season
2 finale my video for that will post on friday
just like normal so be sure to enable alerts for
my channel so you don't miss any of those videos
congratulations david go you're the giveaway
winner from my last big marvel trailer video
please email me on the about page of my channel so
i can get your contact details everyone click here
to re-watch that loki trailer a billion more times
and click here for my new mandalorian season 2
episode 7 video thank you so much for watching
everyone stay safe i'll see you guys tonight!